you guys never pray for something or
wish upon a star for something and then
realize that something's just never
gonna happen that was me for a new
side-scroller Metroid game and then holy
we have Metroid Samus return it's a
side scroller Metroid adventure I've
wanted this for years don't got to talk
about it
[Music]
Metroid Samus returned the thumbnail
this videos must be made with my samus
can it's not just a fist so Metroid
Samus Returns is a 2d side-scroller
Metroid adventure for the 3ds is
ultimately a retelling of Metroid to
return of Samus return of Samus Samus
Returns dramatically they mean the same
thing the story is after the first
Metroid or metroid zero mission which
ever you prefer Samus then goes to the
Metroid homeworld of sr388 to wipe out
all the Metroid's only the metroids are
evolving so when you fight the Metroid
you don't just fight them in their
Metroid form that you knew from the
first game you fight these advanced
Metroid's every few Metroid's are a
little more advanced you have 40
Metroid's that you have to kill killing
the Metroid's and or getting new
abilities unlock different sections of
the map that you saw before but you
couldn't get to that mechanic in game is
called Metroidvania this is one of the
two games to which that mechanic of
gameplay is actually named after I mean
it's not a straight-up port in terms of
map abilities weapons that you get
there's new stuff in here that was not
in Metroid 2 which is a good thing and
the concept is still the same
essentially it's the story of Metroid 2
I love the fact that they did this from
Metroid 2 because Metroid 2 is such an
important part of a Metroid story the
events of Super Metroid and Metroid
Fusion are directly linked to the events
of Metroid 2 maybe not a lot of people
played it maybe people got it later on
they were like oh every room has the
same color scheme because it's Game Boy
and there's no map no I hope they remake
this one day I mean I'll admit I played
Metroid 2 in the past couple years for
the first time in my life but I also had
a map of the entire thing on my phone
right next to me because there was no
way I was going through this without a
map I don't care call me a cheater do
not give a it was fun but now I'm
glad we have Metroid Samus Returns so
people can appreciate the game that is
it was Metroid 2 and this game actually
has a lot of stuff the spider ball is
the iconic Metroid 2 abilities when you
turn into the morph ball then you can
spider crawl up walls and ceilings with
it that's in here but there are a lot of
other abilities also there's a
rapid-fire ability the map ability is
really it's how you get a map there's no
station that's like oh now you grabbed
the map or you unlock the map no it's an
ability that sends out a blast from
Samus that unlocks a map within the
square it also shows you any spaces that
you can get through you know like maybe
a bomb will work there a missile work
there shows you hidden pass an area some
people like that mechanic some people
don't I thought it was fine the people
who are like that breaks
games that you don't have to use it
there's nothing written that says you
have to use that ability I spam the
out of it because I wanted hundred
percent but the newest thing in this
entire game is a melee counter ability
you push X and Sam let's do a counter
you need to do that because a lot of
enemies when they see you they'll charge
you if you counter them and hit them
with it one shot they die without it
takes a few shots and this adventures
actually pretty long my first
playthrough took me 15 hours to get 100%
the speedrun will take you for most
Metroid games preceding this one take
about three hours for the speedrun right
there by implication is 33% longer and
this what I can say about Samus Returns
it's one of those games when you're done
with it you don't just put it down so
often these days it's like alright I'm
done with the game on the other ship
because there's so much entertainment
that just floods out it's at a hundred
and fifty thousand miles an hour or the
thing that's in my mind right now it's
been so long since I've had this thought
is I want to play through this game
again more efficiently with a better
time as a game you don't want to put
down I have waited so long for a
side-scroller Metroid game not only did
this game not disappoint but it actually
very much impressed me the two
annoyances I have in this game and
comparatively to the fun I had are
actually pretty minor are one the floor
trap this game completely over plays the
floor trap card other Metroid games do
it a couple times what I mean is you
know those floor sections that you stand
on and it immediately just breaks away
and then reforms above you it's a floor
trap only a couple times in this game is
it clear that you're like I'm just not
supposed to get across that floor trap
section yet that's why I can compare it
is just imagine you need to get across a
room and someone's put a little pile of
in the middle of the room in the
worst case scenario you step on it get
annoyed and walk around it and get there
anyway it doesn't really hinder your
ability to get to your goal I even have
them when the floor traps don't provoke
you to find a little hidden passage and
getaway around and the floor traps
simply are there for you too I mean I
got to jump over it I guess all you're
doing is taking one minute off of my
life and after the would be end boss
which is the end boss that was in metro
to return of salmon's there is another
end boss that you run across but it
doesn't feel like a really cool thing
just feels out of place like why are you
here
and it comes across as anticlimactic the
game ending would have been cleaner if
you beat the metroid 2 boss and then go
to the ship that's the end but for a
side scroller Metroid game for me the
things that matter are atmosphere tone
gameplay fun and it excels at all of
that was the fact that it's a very
important chapter in the Metroid saga so
I'm glad other people get to experience
it all so I hope this game does well in
sales well Andrew
exception I want to see another side
scroller Metroid game the story goes
this is actually pitched to Nintendo to
be a remake for Metroid Fusion think
that might be jumping the gun Metroid
Fusion gameplay wise is actually quite
good quite playable now so I'm glad they
did Metroid 2 instead because that is
the Metroid game it could have benefited
from this the most but I'd like to see a
game after Metroid Fusion Metroid Fusion
is the latest of the Metroid games
chronologically speaking it's the last
thing that happened in samus's life so
what happened after that what's the next
chapter spend about 15 years so I'd like
to know the guys in the end Metroid
Samus Returns was fantastic it was a lot
of fun when I was playing the game and I
saw that there was a counter mechanic it
changed everything entirely was that he
was a new mechanic that I'd never seen
in a side-scroller Metroid game it does
piggy back a bit on Super Metroid in
terms of theme like musical thing
doesn't change the fact that Samus
Returns has given me the rare mindset of
cannot wait to get back into it and play
it after I've already beaten it my
internet picks aside Metroid Samus
Returns remains awesome tacular alright
guys so Metroid Samus Returns have you
played it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]